Senate committee. Education
Committee will come to order.
Good morning everybody, welcome
to this informational hearing
here in this very impressive
venue, I will say locker rooms
have come a long way since my
playing days as starting forward
on the Millbrook High School
soccer team, and if we're really
doing this right, we'd have
somebody singing the national
anthem, but let's begin the
hearing. So first, let me begin
my comments by thanking the Los
Angeles 84 Foundation for all of
its support and assistance in
developing this morning's
informational hearing, ensuring
that students and all children
have adequate play and access to
physical activity is essential
to a child's social and
emotional development. And
health, second, I'd like to
thank Kevin Demoff and the
entire Los Angeles Rams
organization for generously
hosting this important
conversation here at SoFi
Stadium today, and I'm very
proud to serve as the chair of
the Senate California State
Senate Committee on Education.
Last year, among the bills I
authored was a measure, SB 291,
which addressed inconsistencies
and inequities in schools across
the state with regard to recess
to ensure that every California
student can be assured of access
to at least 30 minutes of recess
in a standard school day so as
to benefit from the benefits
that accrue from unstructured
play and decompression, that
only recess provides and which
an extensive body of research
has validated. Today's hearing
on physical fitness and play is
a natural next step in that
broader conversation as we
endeavor to build on that
success and explore ways to
bring young people opportunities
for play that will offer
pathways to personal growth.
While addressing the
disconcerting trend toward
inactivity, obesity, and other
behavioral issues among young
people that robust physical
activity has been found to
offset. The title of today's
informational hearing is
Examining Physical Education
through a Play Equity Framework.
Today's hearing will also serve
as the official release of the
2024 California Play Equity
Report. The first of its kind
commissioned by the La84
Foundation, the report provides
a statewide look at play, equity
and insights into the barriers
of sport, play and movement for
kids. The report also examines
the landscape of youth sports
participation and physical
activity across the state, with
a specific focus on underserved
communities and the barriers
that they face. The report's
findings are both eye opening
and inspiring, revealing both
some of the pressing challenges
currently preventing all
children from fully benefiting
from play, sports and physical
activity, while also showcasing
the promise of youth
participation in physical
activity. As part of today's
hearing agenda, the committee
will have the opportunity to
hear highlights of the report
and a presentation from the
Legislative Analyst's Office on
Physical Education, PE funding
in California. In the last
section of the hearing, we will
also hear from a panel of
experts on the benefits of
physical activity and physical
education for students and
communities. In a moment, I'm
going to turn the floor over to
Mr. Kevin Demoff of the Los
Angeles Rams and then to a man
who probably needs no
introduction here, LA legend
Derek Fisher, five time NBA
champion who's now serving as a
coach at Crespi Carmelite High
School here in the L.A. area,
before we do that, are there
other members of the committee
who'd like to make an opening
statement? I have with me today,
my colleague, Senator Lola
Smallwood Cuevas, and my
colleague, Senator Steve
Bradford, welcome Senator
Smallwood. Cuevas thank you so
much, Chair Newman. And it is an
honor to be here and to be in
this amazing locker room, of all
places, to have a press
conversation and a panel and
discussion. One would not have
thought the locker room, but
wow, what what what digs, I am
honored to sit on the state
education committee, under
Chairman Newman, and to serve as
chair of the labor committee for
the State Senate. And I want to
say that this conversation,
though we are talking explicitly
about youth and the role that
sports and physical education
plays in their lives today, the
values and the skill sets that
you learn through that process
will live with them forever, as
we think about what we invest to
address conditions around access
to affordable health care, when
we look at communities,
particularly underserved
communities, black and brown
communities where we see
disproportionate numbers of
folks dying from preventable,
preventable diseases like
diabetes and hypertension, when
we think about workers comp and
how do we ensure safe and
healthy workforce, what are
those values and skills and
traditions that individuals
learn early on in terms of, you
know, body and mind? And I want
to say that this conversation is
about, you know, how we are
intentional about investing in
our youth and in their health
and the role that physical
fitness plays. But it's also
about the sustainability of our
state and our workforce and what
makes our community wealthy. And
rich and whole. So I want to say
thank you to the organizers of
this event, particularly Renata,
who does amazing work, Fernando
Ramirez, LA 84 family want to
thank the Rams for helping to
sponsor this, and Mr. Fisher for
joining us and leading this
discussion today. We will learn
a lot and we'll bring a lot back
to the state legislature to see
what action steps can come out
of this discussion today. So
thank you for being here. And
thank thank you, Senator.
Senator Bradford, good morning.
Welcome. Thank you, Chair
Newman. It's truly an honor to
be here. And let me welcome you
to the 35th Senate District,
where we find ourselves here
today and where I've been
honored to represent for the
last eight years. And to Mr.
Demoff for his leadership, not
only with the Rams of being a
great community partner and my
good friend Massimo and all the
work that she has done through
LA 84 and the important dialog
that we're going to have about
youth activities, movements,
sports. And as someone who
coached youth sports for 16
years, both football and
baseball, I know the importance
of house activity. Physical
activity is such an important
connective tissue to keep kids
involved in their communities,
to develop skills beyond
athleticism, to know what
teamwork is, know what
collaboration is, and
communication skills. And so I'm
excited about this. This study
is critically important because
as we see the increase in
childhood obesity and we know as
stated in some communities, we
do not even have any type of
sports activity for kids to
participate in. Many schools
don't even no longer have grass
fields or basketball courts for
them to engage in some type of
physical activity and movement.
So this report is eye opening.
It's important that we all
understand our role in playing,
in keeping young folks involved,
in physical activity. It
prevents a lot of diseases that
we could avoid, such as
hypertension, like I say,
obesity. And so I'm excited
about having this discussion
today. I thank my colleague
Senator Newman for his
leadership and chair of this
committee. And welcome all of
you, Mr. Fisher, and his
commitment to what we are doing
here today. So thank you for
this opportunity. Thank you.
Thank you. And as somebody who's
been coached by Senator
Bradford, I thank Senator
Bradford and Senator Cuevas for
being here today. And so with
that, the floor is officially
yours. Mr. Demo And again, thank
you so much for your hospitality
this morning. And welcome, thank
you, Senator Bradford. Great to
see you again. Senator Newman.
Thank you for choosing such a
wonderful venue to have this,
conversation. And, Senator
Cuevas, thank you for being here
as well. I would not have
imagined on Sunday when we were
standing in the exact spot,
spraying water all over each
other, that it would be so
buttoned down in here five days
later. As it goes. But the joy
of sports was right here. After
our victory over the 40 niners
on on Sunday. But But this place
cleans up well. And you know,
when we built SoFi Stadium in
Hollywood Park, I envisioned
hosting World Cups and Super
Bowls and the Olympics. And
we're so grateful to have hosted
a Super Bowl. And to have the
World Cup in 2026, another Super
Bowl in 2027, and the Olympics
with the opening ceremonies and
swimming in 2028, I never would
have imagined we would hold a
Senate education hearing. In the
locker room. Everything else I
could imagine a Senate education
conversation, not so much. But I
do think this is a wonderful
place to remind people of the
power of sports and what it does
to bring community together and
youth together in meaningful
ways. And while we have an
amazing platform with the NFL
and everything we do here in Los
Angeles, so much of our effort
has been around engaging youth
and bringing them into sport.
And, you know, first and
foremost, our partnership with
LA 84 and Renata to make sure
that play equity is something
that spreads throughout Los
Angeles and that youth have
access to after school programs
and to physical education, and
to be able to move their body.
And I think of whether it's our
play 60 programs we engage in
throughout Los Angeles. In fact,
the first public event we did
upon returning to Los Angeles is
a play 60 event with middle
schoolers right here in
Inglewood in 2016. And I think
even last week, we just, you
know, unveiled a new field at
Nickerson Gardens for them to
use for play and youth, where
there was a dirt patch before.
And you think about the
difference it makes in their
lives and just the quotes and
the smiles from the kids on
their faces that they now had a
place to play. Right. And that
is such a an important element
of youth as a parent of
teenagers who do not play and
should, too much of youth time
is spent indoors, you know, on
devices with electronics, and it
should be spent outdoors with
one another engaging. And if we
don't foster that throughout,
you know, our programs and
schools and everywhere else,
then we are doing our kids a
disservice. And I think about
all of the benefits that come
from sports, from health and
fitness to education to
connection to developing mental
toughness and becoming a great
teammate. Those are all can't be
lost in our system. As our kids
grow up, and the things that we
value so much of the Rams when
we draft players, we talk about
a North Star, which is character
and grit and resilience and
toughness and being a great
teammate. Those get developed by
playing and it starts in school.
You don't learn that when you go
to college and play, you learn
that, you know throughout your
journey in sports through great
coaches like Senator Bradford,
if you ever decide you want to
take a shot at the NFL, you up
on that. He will take you. He'll
let us let us know, but you
know, that is why we have been
so engaged with with her group
and why this mission is so
important to us is as the Rams.
And we welcome you to our locker
room. And, you know, if there's
a place to have a discussion, it
is in this beautiful locker
room. This is the first just a
fun fact for all of you in the
85 year history of the Rams.
This is the only locker room the
Rams have ever designed. And if
you're wondering about the
shape, it is in the shape of a
horn, which you can kind of see
up in the roof and overall. So
that is why it is a little bit
strange shape. So, you know, we
sit here at the spear of the
horn, ready to go talk about how
we bring you together. So I
actually have to go to Woodland
Hills to go inspire our not so
young, team to go get ready for
a trip to Chicago. But look
forward to hearing about the
efforts of this conversation and
thank all of you for your focus
and attention on our youth. So
thank you and thank you. And
please, please thank you. And
again, thank you, Kevin, and
thanks to the Rams for hosting
this today, and with that, it is
my pleasure to introduce
somebody we have all known for
many, many years, five time NBA
champion and community leader,
Mr. Derek Fisher. Welcome.
Welcome, Mr. Fisher, you may
proceed when ready. There you
go. There we go. I think it's on
now, thank you, everyone. And, I
am going to apologize to the
people behind me on behalf of my
mom and dad, because this makes
this is a hearing. It makes it
seem way more official this way.
Never allow me to say you can.
You can actually, it's a
wireless mic. You go to the
podium if you like, or you can
sit here or you can sit here.
Okay. That would be awesome.
Okay. With me, please. We're
clearly setting a precedent for
all the other panelists who want
their screen time. Welcome,
Derek, no. Thank you to
everyone. Kevin Demoff
specifically. I know you had to
step out, but to allow us to be
in this space for such an
important conversation is, is
refreshing. I think it kind of
makes the point of how important
this discussion is. I would
assume they do not have many
conversations in this locker
room space, outside of their
team, and I guess now we can
consider ourselves on that list
of folks that have been able to
have a team meeting, for lack of
a better phrase. In this space.
So thank you to Kevin and the
Rams, SoFi Stadium. Thank you to
the committee here, I've seen
each of you in different
settings individually, but it is
good to see you here
collectively, and get a chance
to connect to Renata, who I
consider to be one of my coaches
and mentors and, and people that
have influenced and impacted my
life in a very significant way.
Thank you for this opportunity
as well. And you'll get a chance
to hear from Doctor Parham a
little later who is also,
impacted my life in a very
positive and impactful way, and
all of this is happening
literally through the game of
sports and through sport is why
we're here, if I was not blessed
and fortunate enough to move to
the city of Los Angeles in 1996,
I was asked the question, if I
was a native, Angeleno, and I
said, I am not, although it
feels that way because my entire
adult life I've basically lived
in Los Angeles outside of a
short stint or two and 1 or 2
other cities. And so I do feel
that Los Angeles, Southern
California, the state of
California is truly like home.
The communities matter, the
young people matter, this
conversation matters. So this is
not just a stop in because I
used to wear a Lakers jersey,
this is a commitment to the
community and to the state and
to this district, one of the
first community events that I
attended here in LA was, across
the street at Kelso Elementary,
when I first began my journey
here in Los Angeles. So thank
you to the committee. Thank you
for everyone to stop in and to
be here and take your time, I
there are people in this room
much smarter than I, so I will
not go back and forth on, what
we know the importance of,
physical education and health
and movement and play means to
young people and to all of us,
we I won't forget about it. I
won't leave it out, it is
important that our young people
are active and moving it. It
impacts the brain in ways that,
again, I don't fully I'm not a
scientist, but the way that
activity impacts the brain and
the way we feel about ourselves
on a daily basis, it's so
important. So it's not something
that I'm going to leave out.
Kevin touched on it before he
left. Obviously the remarks that
each of you made, I don't think
we're trying to convince each
other that it's important, I
think we're we're trying to find
a way. And what I want to
emphasize is how it has impacted
my life as a guy that grew up in
a smaller city, smaller state,
limited resource and resources.
And if not for having access to,
not just physical education
during the school day, but also
access after school, to the
right programs and resources. I
played my first organized game
of basketball at a local boys
and girls club when I was six
years old. And for those of you
that are not as wise as I am,
I'll say it that way, for those
of you that are not as as old as
I am, what the Boys and Girls
Club has meant to so many people
as as an after school option,
not only has that been lost in
some ways, and those resources
and facilities been limited, but
we've also seen the reduction in
our schools in terms of physical
education limited PE classes,
and sports has always been a
microcosm for in some ways what
goes on in our society in
general and in particular in an
election year where this is a
part of the larger conversation
around equity and inclusion and
participation and all people
having the opportunity,
regardless of zip code,
residence where you grew up, the
color of your skin, your gender,
you should at least have the
opportunity to access the best
parts of who you are and the way
we can do that here in the state
of California is really through
sport, like we are one of the,
if not the most diverse states
in the country in the world. And
so it actually increases the
pressure upon us to actually set
a bar that is maybe higher than
other states. It puts more
pressure on us to create the
standard for how and why young
people regardless. Again of
gender zip code part of town,
should have access to the things
that will help them become the
best versions of themselves, for
myself specifically, my parents
could not have afforded even
then what it cost to participate
in sports, in particular after
school. If it were not for, as
we know, our free lunch
programs, many of our young
people wouldn't have food. They
wouldn't have breakfast on days
that they attend school, sport
is becoming a very similar
thing. If sports is not made
available throughout the school
day, many of our young people
will not move. They will not be
active. It's that simple. And I
would I would also add many of
the hard lessons that we learned
about ourselves and where we
start to identify with who we
are. In some ways. But the
impact that we can have on the
world that we live in starts to
happen at those young ages, as a
part of a group or a team or
some organization. And while of
course I'm biased toward sport,
it sports to me is such a
uniquely different structure
than other groups and clubs and
organizations, and so I would
just continue to encourage us
all and this is not to speak at
anyone. I'm including myself in
this conversation, to encourage
us all to keep this at the top
of our list of priority. I'll
segue into our young girls as
well before I step away from and
allow this day to continue is,
as we know, our our young girls,
deal with different levels of
limited access and being
underserved and under resourced
and not committed to at the
level that that they should,
and, and so sport is also and us
having these conversations,
making the commitment to the
resources, the time, the effort
that it will take to make sure
we're creating opportunities for
play, for activity, for physical
education, in school, for the
right constructive programs
after school, for our young
girls, it is, I would argue,
more important than it is for
our young boys. We've we've
we've gained the benefit of
decades and decades and
generations and generations of
resources and programs and teams
and systems being created for us
to get to where we want to go.
For 53 men that that control
this locker room week in and
week out, that access in a lot
of ways, has always been there
for them. We've always invested
in peewee football on the boys
side. We've always invested in
boys and girls club basketball
on the boys side, we've always
invested in high level
basketball, football, soccer,
baseball on the boys side. But
we're also lagging in our
commitment to young girls and
young women when it comes to
access to sport. And that also
then plays a role in why it is
inequitable currently and why we
have to continue to invest in a
major way. Because yes, it lifts
our boys up. But we also know as
we sit here in the state of
California with a woman of color
potentially running for and
being a part of the largest
conversation we can have around
what it means to have an
opportunity, regardless of
gender. Sport is the way that we
can have that conversation here
in the state of California for
our young girls now, so that our
young girls now can grow up
seeing and believing that she
can access the best parts of who
she is, and that we don't see
that drop off that starts to
happen at 11, 12 years old for
many of our young girls, because
as the report, you know,
expresses, whether it's lack of
fun, lack of engagement, which
obviously as a coach speaks to
part of the investment in
resources goes to being able to
bring in quality people that
coach and teach our young
people. And we're not leaning on
our parents who are already
paying too much for access to
sports also. Then we're asking
them to coach the teams as well.
And that's not necessarily what
they do and what's not best for
the system. And so, I just want
to wrap by again saying, I know
for a fact that I would not be
sitting here, without the impact
of sports in my life.
Personally, I can't speak for
anyone else, but without being
and not just basketball, I
played basketball, soccer,
baseball, football throughout my
childhood, and at no point did
my parents have to limit my
access to a sport because of the
cost that all the sports were
available, and so that then
allowed me to explore different
sports, different things and
find what was my path to
accessing the best parts of who
I could be. As a young boy, that
loved basketball and loved
sports and so, again, I just
want to wrap up by saying thank
you, allowing me to have this
conversation to spend this time
with you all. I'm looking
forward to the conversations,
the information that we're going
to share, and lastly, again, I
know sports sometimes gets
conflated with a lot of other
things, but it is very simply
one of the greatest unifiers in
the history of this planet.
There's not many things that
bring more people together than
sport, as evidenced by us
sitting here. This collection of
people would not be here if this
was not a conversation around
the importance of sport and why
it is impactful for so many
people. And, as I continue to be
a resident of this community,
this will always matter. I'll
always be here. I'll always want
to serve and be a value. And,
thank you again for the time and.
And thank you, Derek. First, you
know, for your insightful
remarks and, and I actually have
an eight year old daughter who
plays in the eight nine year old
youth basketball league at the
YMCA. And I feel like I heard in
your comments and offer to coach
her individually, really? Let me
thank you in advance for that.
She needs she needs a lot of
work, but but in all
seriousness, thank you for
taking time out of your day to
participate in this, in this
very important conversation.
We're very grateful, and with
that, let me now welcome our
first panelist, Doctor Sha'carri
Bailey, who is the managing
editor at evidence. And Doctor
Bailey. We've established a
precedent here. So come on up
here. Everybody can see you, and
evidence is a public research
and strategic consulting firm
that delivers actionable data
and strategic insights to public
policy, political and corporate
decision makers. And Doctor
Bailey is going to provide us
with an overview of the 2024
California Play Equity Report by
the Los Angeles 84 Foundation.
Doctor Bailey has over 20 years
of experience designing and
conducting survey and focus
group research, and she is a
graduate of Dartmouth College
and earned her master's and PhD
from UCLA. So she's a local
product as well, and we welcome
you today and looking forward to
your insights. Thank you. So
much, Senator Newman. And to
this, esteemed members of the
Senate and the Committee really
appreciate the opportunity and
the privilege to speak to you
today. I'd be remiss if I didn't
thank Renata Simril and the LA
84 Foundation for their
investment and their trust in in
our work. So thank you. And
Before reviewing the study
results, I'd also like to thank
just take a moment to share.
Special thanks to the evidence
research team, which is here
with us today, including our
research and data data analysts
we have with us, Shiran Wang.
Right there, Noah Marcotte.
Caden Sheps will be assisting me
with the PowerPoint
presentation. Also our
president, Raquel Beltran, and
our chief executive, Rodrigo
Bailey. On the data side, we
have with us Pressley Moreno.
And in absentia, we have Ramona
mukherjee and Calvin Byrd. So
thank you very much to the team.
This was indeed a labor of love
and would not have been possible
without the lived experience and
the diversity that we have on
our team. It's a labor of love
for me personally, because I'm a
daughter of South Los Angeles
and the Inglewood area, so it's
really a privilege for me to
share these results as we look
at this groundbreaking study.
You'll see on the first slide
here, some of the distinctive
nature of the data that we've
collected. It provides a fresh
and innovative assessment of
play equity across the state.
And that is the opportunity for
youth independent of their age,
their ability, status, their
cultural, racial or ethnic
background, their sexual
orientation, their zip code, or
what region of the state they
live to have the opportunity to
engage in physical activity,
participate in sports, and to
move parents and youth
demonstrated in this research a
great deal of value for that
opportunity. The study is
distinctive because it is a
first statewide snapshot of both
youth and parents on the issue
of play equity and the gaps in
the barriers that exist. It's
innovative in that it uplifts
the voices of parents and youth
across the state. As Mr. Fisher
indicated, we have great
opportunity here across
dimensions of identity
difference, but also great
opportunity because of the
policy environment that we have
in California, as well as the
resources. We're the fifth
largest economy in the world. So
play equity is something that we
can and we should make a
priority and a reality. The
results are reflective and
representative. We have a
quantitative study as well as
qualitative research. The voices
directly from youth and directly
from parents in their own words
about the issue of play, equity
and participation. It's
groundbreaking in that it
provides a new baseline of
activity levels across the
state. It's the first study
conducted post-Covid as we've
started to gather again and
youth and parents, adults alike,
have returned to some of the
levels of activity. On the next
slide, a bit about the
methodology for our focus
groups. We conducted four focus
groups compiled of parents and
youth across the state. You can
see the outline here. We had a
total of 25 participants and we
segmented these groups by age
for youth because we want it to
be sensitive to the different
developmental and learning, as
well as experience levels by
age. On the next slide, you'll
see some of the richness of the
diversity of the youth that we
spoke to, including a Latino boy,
age 14 to 15, living in Chino,
who said he enjoyed playing
basketball, baseball through
school. But the stress of school
makes it difficult for him to
maintain his activity and
participation. We also spoke to
a native American boy, age 12 to
13, who lives in Eureka in
foster care. He loves
basketball. He got started
through community Center
sponsored league. We also spoke
to a young Asian American girl,
aged 16 to 17, who lives in
Oakland. She told us that she's
been playing tennis
competitively since she was
young, a biracial girl, age 16
to 17, indicated that she
prefers to play, prefers not to
play sports. But she enjoys
relaxed exercise like yoga. An
Asian American girl, age 14 to
15, living in Los Angeles, said
she prefers activities like show
choir so you can see the rich
diversity of those that we spoke
to as a part of this study.
Likewise for parents, and I
won't read all of the profiles
you have them in the report, but
you can see also that we have
rich ethnic and racial
diversity. We have both mothers
and fathers. We have single
mothers, single parents who
struggled to make ends meet and
to keep their children engaged.
We have fathers as well who are
very active, but indicated that
there are gatekeepers and
barriers for participation, we
also spoke to, parents, both
that were upper income, middle
income as well as lower income.
So we really worked hard to
ensure that we captured the
richness that we have here in
California. And we think it also
provides guidance and lessons
for the state. On to the survey
research methodology. We spoke
with over 1600 parents
throughout the state of school
aged children, which represented
a total of over 2600 youth in
all regions. We conducted the
research in just at the end of
spring in May. The margin of
error associated with the parent
data is around 2.4%, plus or
minus a percentage points. It
was an online survey then that
included reaching out to parents
on mobile devices and text to
web, and the results here have
been weighted to match the
distribution of youth and
parents across the state.
Getting into the key findings,
one of the most striking
elements of this research is the
fact that California youth are
not playing enough. The daily
activities for California youth
fall below the recommended CDC
guideline, which is that youth
every day are playing for at
least 60 minutes. You'll see the
exact data on the next slide. We
asked parents how often their
young people for each child in
their household was engaged in
physical activity. The guideline
is daily what we have in
California is 3 in 5 youth.
Nearly 66% are not engaged in
physical activity daily, 34%
are. We have 10%, roughly 1 in 1
in nine who aren't engaged at
all. Their parents say they
never engage in any form of
physical activity at all. In a
state as large as California,
that's a massive number of young
people who are not engaging in
any type of sports, any type of
play, any type of movement,
which was how the question were
crafted. And we believe that
this can be connected to the
fact that we have a vast
majority of youth who do not
have physical education. Every
day. That's something that we
can do about in our public
schools in in particular. So 66%
of California youth do not have
PE every day. On the next slide,
you'll see our second finding,
which illuminates the gaps and
we'll talk a little bit about
the barriers. But significant
gaps exist particularly for
girls. And Latinas and black
females in particular. Youth.
Latino youth overall have lower
rates of daily activity than
other youth around the state.
Youth with disabilities. Those
from low income households, as
well as youth in the inland
Empire, which is defined as San
Bernardino and Riverside
counties. You'll see the
specific data on the next slide,
here on the left, you see the
percentage of the percentages
for youth who are least active.
So 22% of Latino and Black
females, are not are active,
five days a week or more. So
nearly 8 in 10 are not active
every day. Youth from households
with income under $30,000, youth
with disabilities, Latino youth
overall and youth in the Inland
Empire. So rates of activity 28
to 22% are active five days a
week or more. Our most active
youth include white males and
youth from households with
income more than $100,000 a
year. Those are the only two
groups where we have a majority
or half who are active every
day. Next slide. We'll get to
our third finding. The good news
here. And there is some good
news, is that we have made some
progress in exposure to physical
activity, but it's important to
note that 1 in 3 youth report
over the last two years that
they've stopped playing for some
reason. You'll see the specific
data on the next slide, we asked
parents in particular if their
young people had participated in
any kind of sports player
movement, and then we aggregated
those results to, to indicate
what the exposure levels were.
Last school year, 88% have had
some exposure at some point in
the school year to some type of
physical activity, either casual
play or structured play, and
you'll see 11% have not. On the
next slide, we'll get to more
specific details. Nearly 1 in 3
parents say that their child
stopped playing in the last two
years, and you can see
highlighted in the red boxes
where we have the highest rates
of drop off and usually the drop
off is around 12 to 13 years
old. The San Francisco Bay area,
we have a third of youth
dropping off. We have nearly 40%
in the greater Sacramento area
and the rural North, so this is
a top of the state, we don't see
those gaps when we just look at
area types. So we have fairly
even numbers when we look at the
data by urban areas, suburban or
small town. On the next slide
you'll see specifically some of
the gaps by age as well as race,
ethnicity and income level. And
the words of one Asian-American
youth that participated in the
focus groups female student aged
15 to 14 to 15, she says. I used
to play sports. I was mostly in
it to be with friends. We find
that fun and social connections
are really important as well as
to play. Then after a while, all
of the work caught up with me of
going to swim meets and I left
it. And so this tension between
schoolwork and the load and the
pressure, academically and then
not having the opportunity as
well as you'll see in some of
the later slides. So where are
our gaps there? It's those in
households that are earning
under $50,000 a year. And
specifically for our black and
our African American parents,
nearly 2 in 5 who are saying
that their youth have dropped
out of a sports or activity. On
the next slide, you'll see our
fourth finding structured play
matters. So structured play is
designed is defined as those
activities that are organized by
adults specifically to promote
the physical, emotional, mental
and social well-being of youth
as opposed to casual play or
unstructured play. Structured
play, as well as parental
physical activity, serve as
amplifiers that can help us
narrow this gap, five times more
active. Five times a week or
more. So getting closer to that
daily activity rate, you'll see
the specific data on the next
slide, where we break out the
results of daily physical
activity or not, by structured
versus those who are playing
casually. And I'm going to point
your attention to the red bar,
where we have youth that are
playing fewer than three times a
week. The number is 27% for
those who are in structured
play, but jumps to 43. That's a
huge jump, for those who are,
active only casually or inactive
on the next slide, you'll see
the results for parents parental
activity. And we see the same or
similar gaps going on to finding
five costs is a significant
barrier. So we talked about the
drop off rate. Why are youth
dropping out? 63% of parents say
that they have struggled with
the cost of providing physical
activities, engagement for young
people. Most of our parents in
the study said they're paying
about 100 to $500. So when you
see the gaps of drop off by
household income, you can think
about the fact that the cost of
play is also going up, along
with other things. On the next
slide, you'll see the specific
data 63% of parents, including
24% or 1 in 4 who say they've
struggled a lot with those
costs. And in the words of one
white parent, a female from the
rural North, it makes me curious
how many star pro athletes are
out there. Athletes are out
there, but maybe we'll never get
to have that opportunity because
their family needs to buy
groceries. So parents are making
really stark decisions about
whether to participate. We had
another participant in our focus
groups who talked about the fact
that she had to choose between
which of her children were going
to move forward. Her son was
better at sports and also, enjoy
the competition. And her
daughters didn't get the
opportunity to play. So just
really powerful data behind the
gender gap that we see in the
results on the next slide, you
can see the breakdown of how
much impact various factors have
on youth decisions to stop
playing. Cost is at the top of
the list, with 62% saying it's
had an impact, including more
than a third who say it's had a
major impact on their ability.
Loss of interest, time
commitment. The fact that it's
no longer fun. So how can we
make play sports and movement
more fun for youth and then
needing to work to support the
family? Nearly a third are
saying that that is a reason
that they have dropped out. On
the next slide, we'll get to our
final finding. Which is that
parents have a strong value for
play equity. They have near
universal agreement that the
state should provide full
funding, particularly for PE,
but also for other structured
activities. And you'll see the
specific data, on the next slide,
we ask parents or we presented
them with a range of statements
about play equity. And we asked
them, to what extent do you
agree or disagree? In the dark
bar, there is the percent who
strongly agree. So at the top of
the list is that parents agree
strongly that the opportunity to
participate in sports in
physical activity should be
available to all young people.
That's regardless of their
income level, their gender,
their race ethnicity, or their
ability level opportunities to
participate in sports should be
available for all youth,
regardless of ability level. We
had many parents that talked
about and you see in the data
gaps for those with
disabilities, both physical,
emotional, social and cognitive.
So how can we expand those
opportunities, parents also
believe that there should be
more opportunities for students
with disabilities, specifically
and special needs, to
participate in structured
activities or structured play,
and a theme that was common in
the focus groups among young
people was feeling that they
weren't good enough to play,
particularly sports in school or
outside of school. So how can we
make it fun? How can we
encourage young people that it's
okay to play, independent of
your ability, status, or level?
On the next slide, we also show
that parents believe it's
important for the state to fully
fund structured play. Many don't
know that PE is not fully
funded, and you can see here 80%
believe it's very important. On
the next slide, specifically as
it relates to PE, 58% say that
they did not know that the state
does not fully fund PE, as well
as youth sports and structured
play activities. And finally,
I'll leave you with the data on
the enrollment in physical
education, where we also see
gaps. I mentioned earlier that
we have a high majority of
youth, 57% that do not have PE
every day. And those gaps are
particularly high for young
children. So five to nine who
may or may not have recess,
children in the greater
Sacramento, area, 76% do not
have PE every day. That's pretty
stark. These are pretty strong
numbers. 74% of youth in private
or parochial schools, 73% of
children in public charter
schools, 68%, in San Diego,
Orange and San Francisco Bay
area, those are counties, 66% of
children whose parents are Asian
American or Pacific Islander.
And then finally 64% of female
youth. So with that, I'd like to
thank you for your time and
attention. And thank you. So a
couple of questions, and so, you
know, we're going to give some
space for questions from my
colleagues. Let me start in
Doctor Bali, thank you again,
for your presentation. As you
mentioned, you know, PE is not
fully funded. And frankly, this
is one of the reasons we're
having this hearing today to
gather data and start making a
better case for doing that. And
in doing that, also collecting
better data as to what works and
what doesn't, which communities
are most affected. But let me
ask you this question. So, you
know, how should we then think
about the differences between
PE, which is kind of the classic
gym class, and then physical
activity more generally in the
schools. And how can schools
better incorporate physical
activity even against the
constraints that are making it
harder to deliver gym class?
Yeah, it's a very important
question. I think I mentioned
earlier, PE or physical
education is such a great
opportunity because we know that
we can do something in schools,
and we also know that majority
of youth are coming into contact
with physical activity as a part
of school, as opposed to outside
of school or warmer casual play,
and so I think it's the
opportunity to have something
structured and also supervised
by an adult, but as you saw from
the range of youth that we
included in the focus groups,
there are different types of
activities that youth are
interested in, some are really
invested in what we see as more
traditional sports, and we know
that running and soccer are
among the top activities or most
common activities that youth are
engaged in. But there are also
things like show choir, which we
may not, top of mind think of as
a physical activity. So I think
there are a range of
opportunities we had youth who
mentioned yoga, so it's not just
about sports. It's not just
about gym class. It's about
giving youth a range of ways
that they can engage in
movement, and play. Yeah. I do
appreciate that. And, you know,
Derek Fisher actually touched on
this. You know, too often we
conflate ability and reward
ability and create pathways for
those with ability, especially
in those sort of gender
stereotype ways. But but we
don't recognize the pure
benefits of fun. Right. And
irrespective of ability and
making sure that all kids have
an opportunity to have that
experience. My second question
that I'll open it up to
colleagues, you know, we've
talked about schools, but in
your research, what role can and
should municipalities as
distinct from schools, play in
expanding opportunities for
healthy play? Well, I'll say
there's enough work to go around.
And so there's a great role that
municipalities can play, we had
many youth in our focus groups
who talked about the fact that
while we have parks, we really
only have equipment or access to
playgrounds or sandboxes. And so
I think municipalities can think
about how are our urban
environments encouraging a range
of play through parks and
recreation, but also how can we
invest in community
organizations? We have a good
deal of youth. And you saw that
in the focus group profiles of
youth who are exposed to
community based organizations
and sports and activities that
are available. There So how can
we have local partnerships with
between municipalities, the
philanthropic sector and Play
Equity Fund? And LA 84 is one of
those partners that I know is
working around the state for
those opportunities. And how can
we connect our community based
organizations so that they have
the ability to really work with
us on this issue? I appreciate
that, and one of the things
within that larger conversation
we need to do is figure out ways
that communities can take
advantage of school facilities
and keep them open and available
to the community. When school is
not in session. And too often,
that is, that is not the case.
Colleagues, questions, comments.
Senator Cuevas, thank you so
much, Chair Newman. And thank
you so much, Miss Bailey, for
that. Really in-depth analysis
and some of the data, though not
surprising, is somewhat
stunning, I want to say, when
you see it in black and white, I
have a couple of questions and
one is, this difference between
the 88% of exposure and the 66%
who are not active. I want to
understand the difference
between those two, those two
statistics and where does this
come about investing in PE help
to bridge some of that, and then
the other question I had, just
because we are I was surprised.
I represent the 28th district,
which is South Central Los
Angeles, downtown to Vernon,
sort of Central Avenue corridor
to Mar Vista and Culver City.
And, you know, we have this
issue of being park poor, right?
Not having open space, not
having green space because we're
in this urban environment. But
then when you talk about some of
the rural areas and what's
happening in the Bay area, I was
really shocked by that drop off
and the lack of, of, of activity
and wondering what is going on
between the rural and the urban
sort of what do you think is
leading to that? And I want to
just, you know, as you were
reading those statistics and
going deep into the analysis, I
was thinking about what Mr.
Fisher talked about in terms of
the skills that you get from
play and leadership and sort of
the life decisions and values
and, and way of being in the
world. Right And so when we look
at women, young girls and when
we look at black and Latino
children in this particular
stage, if we just sort of sort
of zoom out and think about, you
know, student education and
achievement when we think about,
you know, socioeconomic
statistics in terms of poverty
and job access, and it's sort of
like this this is sort of like
the first kind of, indication,
right, of where our young people
are going to end up. So I'm
really I really appreciate the
way that you this has been
framed and the way the analysis
is laid out, because this isn't
just about the play, it's also
about where these communities
will end up in our social and
economic environment and in our
state. So those are the two
questions that I had about that
88 and 66%, and the difference
between the rural and urban
environments. Yeah, thank you
for that. Because on its
surface, they seem to be at at
at odds with with one another.
So I want to place it in the LA
context, if you will, because
La84 Foundation has been doing
this work since 2016 at least.
And so we do have tracking data
in Los Angeles County. And so
what we do know is that dating
back to 2016 through 2020, that
exposure was at about the low
80s. So between 83 and 82% of
youth at some point in the
school year engaged in physical
activity, which that makes sense,
right? You you probably had some
form of gym class you may have
tried out for something. So the
question is, have you has your
child for each child in the
household has your child had any
form of physical activity in the
2023 2024 school year? And 88%
of parents say yes at some
point. But access to play and
exposure is not enough. In all.
Play is not created equal. If
youth are not active, every day,
if they're not staying engaged,
we are not meeting what I would
say our responsibility to ensure
that they have the opportunity
for sports play and movement,
because there is a connection
between academic achievement,
mental health, social emotional
health and overall well-being.
For, for engagement. And so the
66% is those who are not active
every day, those who are falling
below the guideline. So the
guideline is not just that you
play at any point, but that you
regularly are active. So it does
no good if one day a week maybe
I'm jumping rope and then I
never get any activity outside
of that. So it's the quality of
play. And I would also add it's
not an either or. So it's not a
not an investment in academics
or career development or college
or time for physical activity.
And there's been a lot of focus,
you know, over education reform,
to think about, you know, math,
reading, writing, arithmetic. We
talk a lot about the arts, but
left out of the conversation is
play equity. And the opportunity
to move. And there's such a
strong connection. It's not an
either or. It's a both and it's
an enrichment of what we're
doing. Thank you. I appreciate
that. I think another question,
you know, Senator Bedford
Bedford just curious, when I was
growing up, we had modern dance
and middle school and high
school. Was there any data as it
related to. We're talking about
movement. And a lot of kids
really loved and participate in
that. Has there been a drop off
in that? And I assume it has as
well, offering those type of
programs as well? Yeah, I, you
know, thank you for bringing up
that point, because we not only
have focus group data that tell
us that youth are interested in
a range of activities. You know,
show choir is one thing I
mentioned, but yoga,
interpretive dance and other
forms of movement were also
important. And we see a bit of a
reverse gender gap, if you will.
So we see many of our female
youth having access to a
diversity of forms of movement,
whereas our male youth are
reporting higher rates of
soccer, baseball, basketball. So
that's a different twist on the
I think how we may traditionally
look at the gender gap. So are
we exposing youth independent of
gender and other dimensions of
identity to a range of ways to,
to play, to have fun, to move,
to engage in, in sports? Again,
thank you so much. Doctor Bali.
Really grateful, and, we now
invite Edgar Cabral from the
Legislative Analyst's Office to
provide a brief overview of
state school funding as it
relates to physical education in
California and, Mr. Cabral, I
guess we follow the pattern, you
can take that seat there. Thank
thank you again for coming down.
Turned out. Thank you. You may
proceed when ready, sir. Thank
you, Mr. Chair. And members of
the committee. I'm Edgar Cabral
with the legislative Analyst
office. Our office is a
nonpartisan advisor to the state
legislature. And so, as someone
who is used to testifying in the
Capitol on committees, it is,
for me, the opposite. Weird to
be, next to you and facing the
audience, but I think I could
all do in a locker room. Yeah.
Yes. In a locker room. Edgar is
used to having his back to the
audience. So, but, I feel like
for me being rude to the members
that I'm in, but you do fit in
well here in this, this sports
venue, thank you again. Thank
you for having me. So, I was
asked to just provide a brief
overview of kind of the state's
role in physical education. So
as we talk about potentially
solutions changes things that we
can do to address some of the
challenges that Doctor Bailey
pointed out in from the survey
that was conducted in the
research. Just to get a sense of
where are we now? What are the
current rules and requirements
and what does the state do in
funding? So I have a very brief
handout. There are a few copies
of it. On the in the back, but
also it's up on our website if
anybody wants to look at it,
it's our website is la Dot
Ca.gov, and I'm just going to
talk about three, three main
areas where the state is
involved. One is setting
specific minimum requirements to
Is funding, and then three is
setting standards. So first when
it comes to the minimum
requirements just talk about
what those are. So in statute
there is a requirement that we
that there's a number of areas
of study that are required to be
provided in public schools. And
physical education is one of
those areas. And it's required
for grades one through 12, the
state also, and this is
something that's unique to
physical education versus other
subject areas. There is a
specific minute requirement in
statute, and that requirement is
for grades one through four, one
through six, at least 200
minutes for every ten school
days. So about 20 minutes a day.
And then in grades seven through
12 to double that requirement.
So it's 400 minutes for every
ten school days. So about 40
minutes a day, one thing I'll
point out, because I think
Doctor Bailey mentioned in the
in, in their survey data, it's
not every day this is an average
over ten days. And so it could
be that some school districts
are lumping that activity in a
couple of days, a week and not
doing it every day. And so that,
that, that may mean that, you
know, there are several days
where there is no structured
physical education in, in a
student's day, I would also
point out that these these
minute requirements, this
excludes recess or the lunch
period. This is a time that's
supposed to be in part of the
school day, part of the
instructional time of a
student's day, the next thing I
would add is there's a
graduation requirement, and that
requirement is that students
complete two year long courses
in physical education to receive
a high school diploma, again,
because it's only two out of
those four years, it could be
that there are some years where
students do not enroll in a
physical education course, and
are not participating in that on
a daily basis, the last thing
I'll add that is a requirement
at the state level is that
public schools must administer a
physical fitness test annually,
and this is administered to
students in grades five, seven
and nine, and for those of you
who went to school in
California, I know, I remember,
I remember at least a couple of
these, and that includes
measures of aerobic capacity,
strength, endurance and
flexibility, so for all this,
there's a few more kind of
detailed requirements, but that
kind of gives you the basic
framework. It's really about
saying, public schools must
provide physical education, and
there's some specific minute
requirements, the Department of
Education does do monitoring of
these requirements annually.
They choose a small subset of
school districts, and they do
audits to monitor whether
there's compliance with the
requirements. And they do
publish a report annually that's
on their website that you can
see where you can find. They
show the number of schools in
each district that they looked
at, and they show if they did
not meet those requirements,
which of the requirements were
not met. And so that's just a
very quick high level on the
requirements themselves. Next, I
want to talk about funding. And
so funding for physical
education, like with essentially
all subject areas in California,
there's no specific earmarked
funds for physical education.
Instead schools are funded
through the primarily through
the local control Funding
formula, which is the main
funding source for schools in
California. And that formula has
a base level of funding that
goes out to school districts and
charter schools based on the
number of students that are that
are enrolled. And then there's
also a component of the formula
called the supplemental grant.
And then the concentration grant
that is, varies across across
districts. That's based on the
proportion of students in each
district that are low income or
English learners. So that those
who have higher proportions of
low income students or English
learners get a little bit more
funding, that that's the primary
funding source for schools in
California. That's where
physical education activities
are primarily being funded. And
so that will include everything
from, staff salaries and
benefits, training,
instructional materials,
equipment that would be funded
through Lcff, there are, and so
I think, I think of that is that
that's the funding source that's
available to fund the
instructional PE requirements,
there are also two other large
programs that the state has that
are for before and after school.
Funding that can also be used to
complement the physical
education instruction to provide
more opportunities for physical
activity throughout the day. One
is known as the After School
Education and Safety program,
which is a long standing
program. It's been around for
more than 20 years. I think
there's about $700 million in
funding for that program, and
that that funding goes out. The
priority is for, school sites
with higher proportions of low
income students across the state
that have access to these funds,
there's also another larger
program that was just created a
few years ago, known as the
Expanded Learning Opportunities
Program. That program goes out
to every school district and
classroom based charter school
in California. And that funding
is provided and with the intent
that there be, before and after
school provided throughout the
school year. And then also that
school districts and charter
schools offer 30 days of a nine
hour programing in what we call
intersession, which could be
summer, but it could also be
winter break. If there's a
Thanksgiving break, days like
that. So this is now a much
broader, pot of money that goes
out across the state that can be
used to complement, other other
programing and physical
activities to promote physical
activity. Now in terms of the
requirements, the requirements
are just that. There be some
educational components in the in
that program and then also
enrichment components and that
enrichment can include a variety
of things. So a lot of times
schools are offering, for
example arts. Or they might be
doing this where maybe there
will be things like Stem
programs like robotics, things
like that. But sports is also
one of the options. That's
available for schools, I would
also point out that I think,
maybe touching back on some of
this survey data that Doctor
Bradley discussed about dropping
off at, at kind of that teenage
years, these before and after
school programs, they're
primarily in the elementary and
middle school grades. So there's
a lot less of these after school
programs in, in the high school
level. So finally, I just want
to touch on, standards that the
state state sets. There are two
different things that the state
does, and this applies to all
subject areas, not just physical
education. One is academic
content standards. So the State
Board of Education adopts
content standards for every area
of study. And these standards
are usually developed with large
groups of experts. They can be,
teachers and people employed in
in school districts, but also
academics and other experts in
the specific subject area to
develop these standards. So
there is there are model
standards for physical education
that were adopted in 2005. There
are also something known as
curriculum frameworks, which is
again something the state does
for every subject area. And
these frameworks essentially are
a way to take those standards
and, and create a template or
one example of how, you can
create a curriculum or a lesson
structure this year to, to
integrate the content so that
students can learn or be able to
do those standards. And so that
is also available for physical
education, those were developed
in 2009, the state does
periodically update these, but
these the physical education
ones have not been updated in a
in a long time, so that
concludes my presentation. I
just wanted to provide a very
high level overview of those
things, but I'm happy to answer
any questions at the appropriate
time. Thank thank you, Mr.
Cabral. I a quick question then
I'll open the conversation to my
colleagues, you mentioned that
the monitoring and enforcement
is done on a kind of a random
audit basis. And your view is,
is that working and is there a
better approach that the
legislature should consider to
ensure that all schools are
trying their very best to meet
their obligations? I think one
one thing I would know is that
there is an this review and then
there is a review and an
occasional and, I don't know how
long it will take before you it
would get back to you that we
would come back and review the
district. I would point out that
this is not a there is no
specific consequences in statute
for not meeting those
requirements. And so that's
something that there is a
finding it will be posted that,
a school district did not meet
those physical education
requirements, but there isn't a
specific. For example, in other
cases we have financial
penalties or other things.
That's part of how the state
ensures that certain activities
are done. I appreciate that. So
you anticipated my follow up
question. So hopefully we'll
hear from some of the other
panelists as to their
recommendations. You know, given
the importance of play, what the
consequences should be if
schools don't meet their
obligations, colleagues, any any
questions or comments for Mister
Gavel? Thank you so much for,
for giving us that overview. I'm
my question has to do with the
requirements, piece of this,
These requirements in terms of
the 200 and the 400, when have
they been revisited and are they
updated? It seems to me, well,
one, the sort of flexibility to
determine how those and it's not
a lot of time, but how that's
allocated is, is challenging for
me, I'm also curious why there's
less in the early years, more in
the sort of secondary high
school, level, I'm just curious
how and when do these
requirements, is it required to
be updated over a certain amount
of time? The other question I
have is where is there in this
process? I see the, sort of the,
the, the framework in terms of
how it's regulated. I'm not sure
the who who determines this are
community based organizations
and school district officials
and parents involved in that
process, is it done strictly,
you know, as part of the
administration, at the district
level, I'm just curious how
these different levers get
decided and who does that? So in
terms of the requirements, I am,
I'm not sure when was the I do
think they're long standing, but
I can get back to you on the
specific time when they were
they were adopted, the, the fact
that they're, I don't have a, I
can guess for you. Why why the
requirements increase over time.
My guess is, in part of it is
that you know, having kids in
elementary school, some of them
will physical activity will
occur whether or not you
structure it or not. At least
with my son, as as students get
older, I think, and there is a
little bit more of a need to
have that structured time to
make sure that that, that, that
occurs, but it is something that,
that, I don't know if there was
a specific what the specific
rationale was and having the
specific way that it goes from
200 to 400 in that time, it is
in general also by the time you
get to middle school, because it
is sort of a standalone course,
there becomes a lot more
regularity to it than, than in
elementary where there is
there's likely more flexibility
in how that's done. Your next
question, I think, was about the
expanded learning funds is that
the more the frameworks, but
also the regulation in terms of
who makes the decisions. Yeah.
The framework. So the
frameworks, the, the, the rules
and regulations, I think the
legislature enacted these, these
laws, the Department of
Education is, is the one that's
reviewing to monitor compliance,
there again, they're following
statute that's in place and then
and then trying to monitor and
oversee it, the, the frameworks
and the standards are,
ultimately adopted by the state
Board of Education. But there
are usually committees that are
developed when these when
they're developed that, that,
that work on, coming up with
that draft, the draft frameworks,
the draft standards that usually
usually it's a very large group
of people in the community.
They're often, school teachers
in the state of California,
principals who have expertise in
the area and often academics who
maybe who have specific content
expertise, that's typically
who's included, whether or not I
think, a community that's I'm
not sure, but I can get back
back to you on that. Yeah. I
think I would love to know
because I think this is a
question of resource. And as we
heard, there's sort of an a
level of expertise in terms of
what kind of movement, what is
the interest of community who
actually provides those services
and ways to build build
partnerships. So I really would
love to see who makes up those,
those decision making bodies.
And then just on the foundation,
you know, we're on the timing. I
have have a I just sent my
daughter I took my daughter to
college last weekend. So I know
a little bit. And I have a son
that's on four soccer teams. And
I had to take a loan out,
really, for the club teams. It
was incredible cost. But I say
that we're in or if we're laying
a foundation. Right. So I
understand children are busy,
right. But we're talking about
structure. We're talking about
building skills. We're talking
about understanding how to care
for your body and what your body
needs. I think, you know, if
we're laying a foundation, it
seems to me we should be really
investing in that structured
time intentionally younger, so
that as they get to middle and
high school and adulthood.
Right. These are foundational
pillars of how they lead their
lives as individuals, in terms
of their health and being really
mindful of their body, mind and
spirit. So I I'm glad that we
know that these are long
standing, but it seems to me
that these requirements have not
actually been discussed and
maybe touched, as you said, in
some time. So I think that's
something we would like to look
at and get more detail on. Thank
you, Senator Bradford. Thank
you. You said funding is based
on Lcff for these programs, but
I'm curious, is daily attendance
part of this or enrollment as
well? So it's based on
attendance. So yes, it's on
attendance. Yes, yes. And so
regardless of how few people
participate or how many people
that fund. Yeah, it's based on
overall attendance. Yeah. In the
in the school day. Not specific
to a specific program but yes.
Yes. So it is, the baseline is
starting with what's the average
daily attendance in the school
district. And then building from
there. Okay. And so let me add I
mean, Senator Cuevas has touched
on something really important.
And it's really about the
allocation of time. And in my
experience, especially with
administrators, you know, for
and I'm semi sympathetic. But as
you talk to superintendents,
principals about, you know,
meeting their obligations,
whether they're explicit,
whether they're in statute or
whether they're obvious in this
case, by providing enough space
and room for kids to play, we
have created a situation in
California where time is the
most precious and inflexible
commodity for administrators,
and it's incumbent upon us to
one prioritize, but also to find
the resources to expand the day
in ways that make sense. And so,
you know, with the expanded
learning opportunity programs,
that's a step in the right
direction. But those are not
permanent programs. And so one
of my goals as the chair of
education is, is to better align
the workday with the school day
and until we do that, I don't
know that we're going to be able
to succeed in many of our other
objectives. And we've made some
progress on that. But but we've
got to make sure as a
legislature that we provide not
only the resources, but the
guidance and the priorities to
do that. And so, Mr. Corral,
thank you so much for your
overview. I appreciate you being
here. And speaking of play. So
at this time, we're actually
going to have a ten minute
movement break, and it's led by
Playworks, Playworks is the only
national nonprofit organization
focused on play during the
school day and play's potential
to bring out the best in every
child. So please welcome Janelle
Matthews, regional partnership
manager, and Fred Barrera, who's
a program manager from
Playworks. And they're going to
get you all kinds of tired and
sweaty here in the Rams locker
room. All right. Good evening.
In favor?
Of.
The.
Play.
Thank.
You.
Angeles. And Renata, more than
anybody here today is
responsible for convening
today's hearing. So give her a
round of applause. And, Renata,
if you could let's panelists, as
I sort of introduce you, make
your way, the next panelist.
Really impressive. Young man.
He's the founder and CEO of
sports for kids, he he is all of
15 years old, making me feel
like a massive underachiever,
and attends Francis Parker High
School in San Diego, when Arden
saw that low income schools were
losing athletic coaches and
physical education teachers, he
took action and founded sports
for kids, Arden has actually
been recognized at the national
level by the President's Council
on Sports, Fitness and
Nutrition. He's one of 30
community champions across the
whole nation. Welcome, Arden.
Also on the panel, Renee
Ramirez, who is the principal at
Armenta Elementary School in the
Los Angeles Unified School
District, principal, Ramirez is
an advocate for holistic
education. He emphasizes the
importance of providing students
with opportunities to develop
both academic and character
skills. He strongly believes
that these skills are essential
for shaping responsible global
citizens who will make
meaningful contributions to
society and to their
communities. And our next
panelist, Doctor Hannah
Thompson, if you could all come
up as I introduce you, Doctor
Thompson is an assistant
research professor at the UC
Berkeley School of Public Health
with expertise in evaluating
programs and policies related to
physical activity, nutrition,
and youth health. And Doctor
Thompson, I would like to know,
was also immensely helpful in
the work I did last year with
with my staff, in the successful
passage of SB 291, which I
mentioned earlier, which
mandates a baseline standard of
30 minutes of recess per day in
California schools, and which
also, importantly, prohibits the
denial of recess to students for
petty disciplinary reasons. And
the final member of our panel is
Doctor William Parham, who is a
professor of in the counseling
program and director of the
School of Education center for
Trauma Informed Education at
Loyola marymount University.
Doctor Parham also serves as the
inaugural director of the Mental
Health and Wellness Program for
the National Basketball Players
Association. Among his many past
achievements is his service as a
member of the California
Governor's Council on Physical
Fitness and Mental Well-Being,
as well as a as a member of the
California Science Foundation.
Science of sport Advisory
Committee. Welcome, everyone,
and, Miss Schimmel, if you
wouldn't mind kicking us off,
please begin when you're ready.
Well, thank you, thank you,
Senator Newman, for that
introduction. And permit me by
first starting, starting out by
thanking the Los Angeles Rams
for hosting this, convening my
team at the LA 84 Foundation,
and specifically Fernando
Ramirez, who led efforts in
partnership with your office to
put this hearing on. And to my
friends and colleagues, Senator
Bradford, Senator Lola
Smallwood, my friends and my
colleagues on this committee,
thank you for your bold
leadership today. Today's
education hearing is a
significant milestone in the pay
equity movement. When we started
this movement six years ago, we
said that pay equity was a
crisis hiding in plain sight.
I'm honored today to say that it
is no longer hiding in plain
sight. We're bringing it out to
the forefront and the actions
that we will continue to take
together, I believe, will change
the trajectory of California
youth far into the future, and,
you know, on a personal note, I
was one of those statistics you
heard me speak of earlier today.
A girl from Carson, California,
just down the 110 freeway or the
405 freeway, depending on which
way you go, navigating the
perils of economic barriers,
mental health challenges, gangs
and drugs within my own family
and within my community. But I
was fortunate to benefit from
the power of sport, play and
movement in my public school,
Lakewood Elementary. Carson
Curtis Junior High School, and
ultimately Carson High School,
where I played baseball. And
excuse me, I didn't play
baseball, but I did play
baseball, but basketball and
tennis. And it was through PE
and middle school that I was
able to sample a variety of
sports to find what I was good
at. But sport also helped me
find my strength and my voice to
navigate these obstacles in my
family and my communities and
build pathways to an
extraordinarily enriched life.
Sports kept me engaged in
school. In fact, it was the only
reason that I showed up for
school on some days, and as it
turns out, sport sports were
absolutely seminal for me,
developing resiliency that I
needed to make it through Army's
basic training, which ultimately
became my pathway to college.
And I can say without
equivocation that I would not be
here in front of this committee
if it weren't for sport and
movement in my life. So I'm
humbled to serve as the
president and CEO of the L84
Foundation, a legacy of the 1984
Olympic Games. It's celebrating
40 years this year, and with the
FIFA World Cup 26 and the LA 28
Olympics and Paralympic Games on
the horizon, we are a model for
what long term impact looks like
resulting from major sporting
events in our state. And for
four decades, we have helped
build pathways to enrich lives
through sport, play and
movement. For millions of school
aged children. We have trained
thousands of coaches and rebuilt
safe, public safe spaces for
kids to play throughout the
region, and we commissioned this
2024 California Play Equity
Report with one specific
objective in mind to deepen the
impact of our work and to close
the play equity gap. And I
invite the committee to reflect
on three takeaways today one,
the power of joy and fun two
advancing a play equity
framework in our policymaking
and three political will, joy
and fun. As you've heard earlier
today, the time commitment
required to continue playing
loss of interest friends,
quitting and competitiveness
emerge as the top reasons that
it had a significant impact on
youth leaving sports. We can't
ignore the significant
differences in dropout rates
reported across race and
ethnicity and gender, but I was
particularly struck by the fact
that 2 in 5 parents, nearly 43%,
say that sports was no longer
fun for their children. As a
nation, we need fun and joy in
our lives and our and in our
communities. Now more than ever,
our U.S. Surgeon General has
raised that as a nation, we are
socially disconnected and facing
an isolation epidemic, and our
youth are at the epicenter of
this isolation in a
disproportionate amount of kids
of color are struggling with
stress, anxiety, and depression.
My own son being one of them.
Sports bridges divides and
brings people together and in
the right environment with
caring adults. Play in sports
can serve as an arena of
belonging. It creates a level of
spontaneous co-creation and
interaction. We saw that today
with Playworks and the
demonstration we did in just ten
simple minutes and it builds
community in the process. We
need to provide more time for
children to experience the joy
of community through sport and
play. And how do we do that? I
believe we do that through play
equity. As a framework. We need
to lead from a play equity
centered framework in all of our
policy work in the state of
California, and play equity as
it was mentioned earlier, is the
concept of ensuring that all
children, regardless of their
backgrounds, have equality of
access to play opportunities,
sports programs and healthy
movement. It recognizes that
sport and play are essential for
a child's physical, emotional,
social and academic development,
and that disparities across
sports and play have perpetuated
inequalities in other areas of
life as well. Rates of physical
activity are lowest for black
and brown girls, youth with
disability and low income
households. As you heard
Sha'carri mentioned today, this
means that we must center those
on the margin in our policy
making and to rethink the school
day to prioritize and to make
time for sport, play and
movement and the final point is
political will. I would put
forth that political will is
key. The policies and
legislations that we put in
place that are
disproportionately creating this
play equity gap are the same
political will that we can
address to fix them. So today's
hearing is a great step toward
moving this work in action,
greater funding for sport and
play in initiatives that focus
on equity will not only improve
access to sports and physical
activity for our youth
experience inequitable
opportunities, but it will
further ease the barriers of a
parent's economic burden by
providing more resources for
childcare in an after school
setting. Parents overwhelmingly
support action by the state of
California to provide full
funding to support to full
funding to support structured
play and physical activity. As
you heard earlier, nearly 95% of
parents believe it is important
for the state of California to
provide full funding for youth
sports. PE and structured play.
Likewise, an overwhelming
majority of parents, 86% said,
as you heard, support more
funding at the state level and
local level for play equity
initiatives that expand
opportunities for all young
people. Leadership matters, and
I'm inspired by the leadership
that this committee is taking
today. And let me close you with
this. Thank you. Thank you for
prioritizing this crucial
conversation. Thank you for all
of you who are in the audience.
Many organizations that we've
worked with over the last ten
years since I've been leading
this organization, to close the
play equity gap. I think
together we can ensure that
every child, regardless of their
zip code, can move, play and
thrive. Together, we can build a
future where equitable access to
physical education isn't a
privilege, but it's a right that
every child has because the
health and the potential of our
children depend on it. So thank
you. Thank you. And thank you.
And Mr. Paulo, welcome. Please
proceed. Thank you so much,
hello. My name is Arden Paula. I
am 15 years old, going on 16, I
live at Francis Park. I go to
San Diego, I go to Francis
Parker High School, the reason
I'm here today is to talk a bit
about my organization that I
started three years ago, sports
for kids, and our mission is to
allow youth volunteers to better
the lives of the low income and
homeless through athletics and
community engagement. My story
started when I first volunteered
at a title one elementary school
in San Diego for a book reading.
Perkins elementary is a school
in San Diego with more than 30%
of their students that are
homeless, and the other 70% that
are low income and once, while
the principal was walking me out
after I'd finished the book
reading, he happened to mention
to me that the school
unfortunately had to let go of
their athletics coach. Now, this
really got to me because during
that same time I was really
getting into basketball and I
knew how much basketball really
changed my life. I became more
confident in myself, more
physically active and more
mentally healthy. And knowing
that these kids at this school
wouldn't have that same chance
to fall in love with the sports
the same way I did, really
pulled on my heart strings. So I
felt inclined to do something
about it. So for the rest of
that year, I became a volunteer
coach for Perkins Elementary. I
coached between 6 to 8 kids
every Wednesday for on an hour
and a half. I had no intention
to make this a nonprofit. I just
wanted to do good to the
community. But when I discovered
the impact, this extra 1.5 hours
per week had on these kids, I
decided to make a change. These
kids were. Besides playing
sports and becoming more
physically active, these kids
became friends with each other
and even outside of the sports
clinic, they were hanging out
and having fun. Plus that they
genuinely wanted to play sports.
On the last day they asked me,
when are you going to come back
next? Next week? Next year? They
genuinely wanted this, and that
prompted me to do some more
research about the situation.
And over the summer I discovered
that approximately 125 schools
in San Diego have more than 70%
of their students that are low
income. And of that, I contacted
around six and all those schools
told me that they don't have a
structured athletics program.
This research motivated me to
create sports for kids. We
started with one sports clinic
at Perkins Elementary, and we
coached almost 80 students that
year. We gave those kids an
extra 17 hours of physical
education that the school would
not have to provide the
resources for fast forwarding to
today, sports for kids runs
various programs across multiple
schools in San Diego, and we've
served almost 500 low income
students throughout our
operation. Alongside that, we
are heavily driven by youth
volunteers. Our team director of
Social Media communications and
outreach are all youth led
positions. Alongside that, we
also have a professional coach
going to these schools during
our sports clinics to ensure
that these kids get proper good
sports education. However, we
also have youth volunteers
assist in coaching these
professional coaches to get the
youth involved in the face of
change. There are so many
stories I like to share with you
today about my time
volunteering, coaching and
leading sports for kids and I'd
like to share one with you
before we go to the next
panelist. And it's about this
kid named Abraham. Abraham was
one of our program's most shy
participants. He navigated his
way through a physical
disability all his life, and he
never really felt comfortable
participating in sports at
first. He was very reserved in
our program, understandably so.
But as the program moved on and
he got more comfortable, he
started to show his true colors.
He played basketball and he
really liked it. And by the end
of the sports clinic, he was the
team captain. And he was
shooting three pointers, dunking
even. And he was it was crazy. I
mean, he was having the time of
his life and what astonished me
the most was that the principal
pulled me aside and said, I've
never seen Abraham like this
before. I'd never seen him
participate in any physical
activity, and he doesn't really
talk to anyone outside of
sports, so this was a complete
new side of Abraham that he was
seeing. And that is what my
program is all about, bringing
youth together through sports
and giving them a space to have
fun. Sometimes having having fun
is all kids really need. So
thank you so much for this
opportunity, and thank you for
letting me share my story.
Senator Newman, with the
committee's indulgence, I would
like to recognize Arden's
parents who are here, and give
them a round of applause. Just
an extraordinary young man.
Principal please be seated. Yeah.
Is that one working? Yes, yes.
That's on. Oh, cool. There you
go. Hi, Rene Ramirez, principal,
Arminta Street Elementary, I'm
going to give a boots on the
ground report on the current
state of PE and physical
activity in la USD. I'm a
principal at an elementary
school, and I've worked at
another elementary school. Not
too far from here. Sixth Avenue
Elementary and pretty much the
same has the state of physical
education has stayed the same,
at least from my perspective,
across the district, in
particular, in elementary
schools. So as was mentioned
earlier, there is a requirement
for 100 minutes weekly of
physical activity that equates
to about 20 minutes a day, but
it doesn't always work that way.
As some of the panelists said
earlier, sometimes it's broken
up to two days, maybe three
days, and at the same time, the
quality of that 100 minutes.
Yes, you know, I can go out and
monitor in the midst of all of
the other things that I'm doing,
like the senator had said and
all these other things that are
happening at schools, I have to
go monitor the PE, taking place
across grades. First through
fifth at our school, and it's
taking place, but the quality of
it is just not there. And that's
no fault of the teachers, no
fault of the district. It is
what it is. The teachers don't
come in with that training or
expertise to give a quality,
comprehensive, PE program. And
on top of that, we have, you
know, an aging population of
teachers. So those teachers that
are near the end of their
career, you know, they just go
out with a kick ball and say,
here, that's, that's about the
extent of the PE program as a
kickball. So we have plenty of
kickballs, if we're lucky, we do
have those young, energetic
teachers that are coming in out
of college or wherever, and they
do have that background. They do
tend to provide, you know, a
quality, decent PE program. But
in terms of comprehensive, you
know, building teamwork,
collaboration skills, that
activity that we just did
earlier with Playworks is just
not there. So that is the 100
minute component, not to mention
we also have teachers that just
aren't that out of shape
themselves so they don't have
any motivation. So neither will
the students, so we hear a lot
about equity. The equity
component is definitely, a
concern because as you know,
students that are in my school
in particular, over 90% free or
reduced lunch, our lcap money,
the money that we could be
spending on PE teachers or
physical activity programs we
have to spend on the social
emotional development of our
students because we're now not
just a education institution.
We're also a social service
institution. Schools in
particular in the inner city,
have become social service
institutions. And that's just
the reality. So we have to spend
our funding, our lcap money on
counselors, attendance
counselors, social workers,
psychologists, interventionists
to get the kids caught up
because most of the kids are at
least 1 or 2 grade levels
behind. So the free money that
we do have, we have to spend on
social services and social
emotional services and, whereas
if we had funding for a PE
teacher or a play program, that
would actually motivate students
to come to school as opposed to
sending a PSA counselor to the
door to tell them to go to
school, they would already be
motivated because there's
something there at the school
that they're good at. There's
something there that they have
to look forward to every day.
They may not be good at reading.
They may not be good at writing.
As we know, we all come with a
different set of talents. Those
kids that have that physical
talent, that innate physical
ability to pick up a basketball
throw, a football hit, a
baseball that's been proven that
that we all have something to
offer. And so I try to do that
at my school. I try to give all
of our students as many
opportunities as I can for
success, I work closely with our
after school program to make
sure that they're, giving a
quality sports program at our
school, because that is our
sports program is the after
school program, which they
aren't always quality either.
But, moving along to my last
point I want to make is the
untapped resource that we're
missing with these students that
do have that talent, that do
have that ability to do things
out of the classroom. That's
what I would like to see more
support in, because we are
missing, at least at the
elementary level, a huge
opportunity, for, tapping,
resources in our, in our
students, the leadership skills
that come along with these types
of programs can be seen pretty
clearly at, at an early age. So
that's why I'm a firm believer
in developing these as early as
we can. At the elementary level.
We're not seeing enough of the
state funding for schools. The
PE tip program. It's all the
district has. If they didn't
have that program, we would have
no PE program. Right now. We
have 17 PE itinerants for over
400 schools and that by the time
they get to each school, it's
about I think about seven years
by the time that each one of
those gets to a school. So we
would have zero funding if we
didn't have that money and the
title for money, of course, but
we just need more support and
that's what we're asking for
here today. And thank you. Thank
you. Mr. Thank you, Principal
Ramirez, Doctor Thompson,
welcome. Hi. Thank you so, is
this on? Not yet. Not yet. Come
in. I think so now. Yeah. Good.
Hi everyone. My name is Hannah
Thompson. I'm an assistant
research professor in the School
of Public Health at UC Berkeley.
And I've been studying physical
activity and specifically
physical education in schools
for the past 15 years or so. And
my first job out of college was
actually as a middle school PE
teacher in Oakland Unified. And
I will say I'm grateful that
this locker room smells better
than the changing area. And that
middle school, which I still
think about sometimes, but that
job is really what is sort of
motivated and informed. A lot of
the work that I have done as an
academic over the past 15 years
in partnerships with schools and
school districts. And to your
question earlier, Senator
Newman, the CDC recommends
something called a comprehensive
school physical activity plan,
which is sort of an outline for
how schools can get students
those recommended 60 minutes of
moderate to vigorous physical
activity during the day. The
Institute of Medicine actually
has recommended that that
happens during the school day,
specifically because of a lot of
the play equity issues that have
been born out in this report,
because most students don't
actually have opportunities
outside of school. And of that
school comprehensive of that
comprehensive school, physical
activity plan, physical
education is really the only
opportunity that affects
students throughout their school
career, right? Elementary school
students have recess. Not all
students live in a neighborhood,
or it's accessible to walk or
bike to school. Not all students
participate in after school
programs. So PE really from a
public health perspective, is
really the most equitable
opportunity we have to reach
students, regardless of their
background and to help them get,
you know, physical activity in
the present day. But to really
learn the skills that facilitate
being an active adult, to going
on and being active later in
life. And so when I wanted to
just mention two studies that
we've done over the past few
years in California, the first
was a survey of how many
elementary, single subject
credentialed elementary PE
teachers we actually have in in
our public schools here in
California. This was right
before Covid, and half of our
school districts in California.
So over 300 school districts
that educate elementary students
did not have a single subject
credentialed PE teacher on
staff. So most PE was being
taught by Multi-subject
Elementary School teachers who
maybe got 1 to 2 years of PE
training during their
credentialing program. We also
found that schools with a higher
enrollment of minoritized
students were least likely to
have PE teachers, and schools
with more lower income students
were less likely to have PE
teachers, so real equity issue
there. We took it a step further
and then looked at the
association between having a PE
teacher and students
cardiorespiratory fitness, their
heart health and schools that
had PE teachers had students who
were healthier, who had who
performed better on tests of
aerobic capacity. So having PE
teachers is there's a clear lack
in California and that is one
way to open up the pipeline. I
do a lot of work with the New
York City Department of
Education, which is the largest
school district in the country.
They they serve as a great model
for the 5% of their schools used
to be in compliance with their
state PE law, and now they have
a huge number of schools in
compliance through some of the
work that they've done. So there
are models out there that exist
to doing PE better. We just have
some opportunities to follow
those. The second study I wanted
to mention quickly is I'm sure
many of you know, because we
have PE is one of the only
subjects where we have a minute
mandate here in California
several years ago, about 140
school districts in California
were sued by a lawyer for being
non-compliant with our state PE
law. And this, the lawyer made
millions of dollars directly
from schools that schools had to
pay to him for being
non-compliant. We actually went
out and studied the impact of
this lawsuit. We talked to lots
of school district
administrators, lots of school
district principals to ask them
how they felt about the lawsuit.
They didn't like the approach,
but they liked the fact that all
of a sudden now people were
talking about PE and they felt
like it was able to be elevated
up their priority list. Oh, this
actually is something that's
going to happen that has to
happen, and we will get in
trouble if it doesn't happen
right. So this speaks to that
accountability piece, right? I'm
not saying lawsuits are the
solution. They're certainly take
money away from schools.
However, we do need a stronger
system of accountability and
some actual, penalties and or
benefits if you do actually
comply with the law. The second
thing we also found, again, sort
of supporting what we had seen
in the earlier study is that
schools that were parties to the
lawsuit, we saw increases in
student cardiorespiratory
fitness in those schools because
they actually started doing PE.
So there was a direct benefit
seen from actually doing PE,
again, borne out in students
heart health, which is
something, you know, we care
about on so many different
levels. Thank you and thank you,
thank you, Doctor Thompson,
Doctor Parra, welcome. Thank
you. And I certainly want to
first and foremost give
acknowledgment to Renata Simril,
who really is sort of the coach
of this whole team. And I really
want to give her can we give her
a round of applause? But the
other thing I want to say, I
really am, a practicing
oncologist, psychologist for 40
years, have taught and worked a
lot with elite athletes, and I
can't begin to emphasize in a
short amount of time that mental
health is, in fact, the
cornerstone of everything we're
talking about. So mental health
is a state of well-being that
influences how we think, feel
and behave. We don't do anything
else but those three things. It
really does significantly impact
how we make decisions. It
impacts our relational capital,
how we interact with people. It
significantly impacts how we
envision the future. It is
deal with disappointments and
reconcile all of that. The truth
of the matter mental health and
solid mental health and
participation in play, sport and
activity, particularly organized
activity, builds a sense of
confidence. It builds
competence. It builds a sense of
agency that I can do this. It
helps you negotiate. Challenges.
Some that are predicted, some
that are not. It really is the
fundamental core of everything.
Everybody does. It's an
opportunity that we are missing
when we don't tap into promote,
active activities for kids. I
don't know any kid. I don't know
anybody in the audience who
breathes every other day, whose
heart pounds every other day.
Your mental health doesn't take
a break every other day. It is,
in fact, a fundamental core of
who we are. And I certainly want
to applaud the Committee for
really exposing what's been
hiding in plain sight. I also
think it's not an accident in
the timing of this particular
meeting, because in parallel, it
was mentioned by Renata Simril,
a parallel port report came out
by the US Surgeon general at the
end of 2023. Isolation and
loneliness is at an epidemic
proportion globally. Not in
California, not in United
States, globally and again at
the epicenter are our kids. I
won't go into the data on that,
but I will add one other context.
Social media reports are coming
out that are just scathingly
important to look at. They are
really robbing the center and
the core of our youth. Who are
the most vulnerable, most
receptive to social media that
is largely unsanctioned and
unregulated. People say what
they want when they want, how
they want and to whom they want,
and translate that language on a
screen to see an in-person
athletes as avatars. And so when
you get to these arenas, they
say what they want to them. I
think we're missing an
opportunity not to understand
that context. The last
contextual frame that I will
offer is this. When I've read
this report and many others, it
really underscores for me a
fundamental premise to some how
the system has failed at really
addressing these needs.
Personally, I don't buy that. I
don't think the system has
failed at anything. I think the
system has succeeded at not
addressing these issues. And so
for me, the invitation and the
opportunity is and the question
on the table, does the system
want to succeed differently?
Thank you. And And so thank you,
Senator small. Senator Bedford,
any questions comments. Go
ahead. Well just really
appreciating the question. And
thank you so much Art. And for
the work that you've done. And
just I want to say how
inspirational I think we're
talking about the future. We're
talking about vision. And this
is the leadership that we want
to see, I the question that I,
and I don't know if it's more of
a question or a comment, but
what's being raised here, and
curious where and particularly
the studies in New York and
other systems, when you talk
about public health and you talk
about mental health, certainly
in California, we have in the
legislature done a lot to
prioritize mental health
services, the voters approving
prop one. And I'm curious when
we think about this foundational
work with our students and our
and our schools as social
services centers, are are other
states looking at other resource
funding streams to braid into
this, that it's not just
educational dollars, it's not
just, you know, because our
system in California, we have
one of the most amazing
educational systems in the world
from, you know, from K to 12 to
higher ed, the voters have
committed to that system. And we
often are always looking where
is the revenue to ensure that we
continue to invest there? But I
don't know if I want to say, is
there an opportunity to see how
we might look at other places
for resources? Because what
we're getting at here is, and I
think, the last speaker touched
on this is really creating that
discipline to understand your
body, to understand how to
regulate your your mind, your
body and your and your soul and
to, develop that awareness early
so that it lives with you for
the rest of your life. So I just
want to get a sense of are there
other places where we're seeing
creativity in this funding,
where we're seeing some
collaboration? And then I have
one other question after that.
Yeah. So speaking to New York,
the what New York did, they did
this four year program called P
works. And that was actually
started by mayor, then mayor de
Blasio. And so it came from a
mayoral initiative. He invested
$100 million across the city's
nearly 17, 1800 schools to
improve P. So he saw it up at
that level as so deficient and
in so much need of work that he
was able to get city council
funding and to do it that way.
I'm sure other cities, and I'm
sure other people might have
good examples of how it's
happening other places. But I
think and I've talked to Senator
Newman about some creative
ideas, I've had, which have
included taxing sports team
tickets. We have more
professional sports teams than
any other state, and you know
what? If we did that and that
was something that went towards
a fund towards paying teachers.
I'm not a money person in that
sense. So I will leave that to
the to the big brains. But I
think there's a lot of room for
creativity. There's appetite for
creativity. If we have the
people who can kind of put that,
put that into action and,
Senator, I would, I would, I
would offer that in our work.
Certainly my work here over the
last ten years, but certainly
the work of the foundation, the
research and the studies that
we've done, you know, over the
trajectory of our 40 years of
doing this work, is that we've
lost the importance of sport
play and movement as part of the
education pedagogy. Is it when
you talk about social emotional
competencies, as you saw with
Playworks, you develop social
emotional competency through
play. You learn self-regulation,
anger management, relationship
development in school is exactly
where those sports play. In
movement and, you know, should
be should be offered and not
just for the students but for
the teachers because our
teachers are taxed. And so, you
know, we don't want to see this
conversation as being punitive
to the school districts and to
the teachers. They need time to
breathe, to take a break, to
reflect. And I think we need to
rethink also how we across the
legislature elevate that sport
is not a nice to have sport
playing movement is not a nice
to have. It's a must have
because when you reference the
mental health bill, which is
extraordinary, it doesn't allow
for directly. And we're working
with the Governor's Council on
Physical Fitness and Mental
Well-Being to look at that
legislation is there an on ramp
for community based
organizations who are addressing
young people's mental health and
mental wellness through sport
and play and movement? Can they
access that $3.5 billion? So I
think there is an opportunity
for the legislature to look at
when we pass a bill. Can we make
that funding available to
coaches in community in schools,
when we look at, obesity bills
that we might pass to reduce
obesity through health and human
services is there an on ramp for
organizations that are using
sport play and movement to
improve cardiovascular health,
to reduce BMI as being able to
access those funding? Because
right now, our experience says
they're very siloed. The last
point that I'll make, because I
know I was having a conversation
earlier with our friends from
the Inglewood Unified School
districts, who are great
partners and really pushing
forward, you know, sport plan
movement in their school system.
Is it schools coming out of
Covid or struggling with truancy
and absenteeism, and we did a
three year longitudinal study
for an after school middle
school sports program that we
funded for. We funded for a long
period of time with the Los
Angeles, with the LAUSD school
system. And it looked at 16
schools within all of the
elementary schools that have our
sports program. And then that
was compared to the after school
programs. And our study found
that students in our sports
program attended schools 6 to 10
days more, on average than
students who didn't. So I think,
and I'm happy to share that that
report, we concluded it in 2000,
2019. So just before the
pandemic, you know, as another
piece of data that demonstrates
the power of sports as a tool
for educational pedagogy. Wow.
Thank you for that, and I really
appreciate the holistic sort of
approach and so many things that
can get addressed through
through play equity and also
recognizing teachers. We hear
from teachers every day at the
state Capitol, and you know,
dealing with conflict
resolution, dealing with so many
issues in the classroom.
Certainly this could be a valve
to release some of that pressure
and tension that exists in some
of our classrooms, the final
question I had is about
barriers. And, Renata, you
talked about relationships that
you have with different school
districts where you're doing
this work. Can you talk a little
bit about what are some of the
barriers that exist between
building these partnerships? I
heard funding, but, you know, we
often think about is it more
technical assistance? Is there
are there other ways, other
barriers that come up that
policy can also help to support,
I think a couple, one that just,
I think just one of the biggest
barriers is, is elevating the
importance and so I just commend
this, this committee on
elevating this topic, it's
crucial to the health of our
kids. I think the other is I was
struck by the legislative
analyst's report is that the
curriculum has not been updated
since 2005, and the standards
haven't. I think it's the other
way around. The standards in
2005 and the curriculum since
2009. The world has changed in
that duration of time. So if
there's one thing that comes out
of this committee, I would hope
that we take a look at,
reframing with today's standards
and the information that we know
about mental health and physical
health and, you know,
opportunities and how kids need
to move. And aligning to the CDC
standards, so I just offer that
as one barrier is that we're not
paying attention. The second is,
I think just communication and
coordination and partnership,
you know, we have a partnership,
a community of practice. It's an
out of school time practice with
Nike, looking at gender equity
in particular. And we it's a
community of practice between
parents, organizations, coaches.
And we did a parent survey.
We're in the second year, the
second term of a three year
project. So we're in the second
three year program with the same
group of 13 organizations. And
the parents aren't on social
media to find out what programs
are available within their
community. For young people, the
parents rely on the school
district to get information
about what are the trusted
organizations that their kids
can participate in, but the
school district and it's just a
flier, right? You see a flier in
the school when you go in PTA
meeting and the school districts
were hesitant of putting that
flier up because they didn't
want to recommend a community
based organization that their
kids can take. And so there was
this sort of feedback loop that
if we just could find a way to
communicate, what are the
organizations within communities
that are providing safe places,
well trained coaches, positive
environments for their young
people to engage, particularly
girls in sport, play and
movement is another, I think,
low barrier. If we just look at
communication, partnerships,
coordination so that the parents
know where the positive
resources are for their young
people to be able to benefit.
And the third, I'll offer is
something that Senator Newman
lifted up is those communities
that are park starved and have
less access. Is can we find a
way to eliminate barriers for
community based organizations or
recreation and parks departments
to open up our schools? During
the weekend and especially
during the summer, because
there's not just a learning loss
during the summer. There's also
a play loss during the summer.
And so can we look at the
Department of Education and
rules and barriers that are
really preventing our schools
for being used as centers of
communities, particularly for
sport play, movement? Thank you,
Senator Bradford. I just want to
thank all five of you for the
insight that you've provided
many times. We as legislators
create policy from a void and
don't have the real world
experience. And you guys have
shown a light shined a light, I
should say, on where those voids
are and what needs to be
addressed. And I just want to
highlight Arden, you're a rock
star, man, and many times we
talk about our youth being the
future. But you're the right
now. You're the right now. And
but it also speaks to what is
lacking in society. When our
young folks have to pick up the
pieces and carry the mantle and
fill those gaps where our system
is, not where government is not.
So I just want to thank you for
all that you're doing. And
again, for our educators for
helping shine a light on where
we can fix it. And highlighting,
how play equity and movement is
that connective tissue to our
overall development and how
important that is. And I totally
agree with Doctor Parham that
the system isn't failing. It's
probably achieving its goal of
doing what it wants to do and
it's by not addressing this
problem and creating the
problems that, you know, many of
us are facing every day, and
they're probably succeeding, as
they want it to be. So thank you
for your insight there as well.
Yeah Agreed. Agreed. So I agree,
I want to ask one quick question
and then we'll get to public
comment. But because I think
it's important to get it on the
record. So as, as has been
noted, you know, the curriculum
has not been revised in quite a
while, but but equally
importantly, during the Covid
period, there was a moratorium
on testing. And by all
indications, we haven't really
reverted back to anything
rigorous since then. I actually
have a letter out to the
governor of the Superintendent
of Public Instruction to get
some clarity as to the plan
there, but but I'd be
interested, doctor Thompson.
Others, what are some basic
measures of success or progress
metrics that we should be
thinking about as we you know,
sort of develop hopefully,
legislative solutions to make
this to move things forward as
it relates to not only access to
physical activity, but also
measures that ensure that we're
properly rewarding good
programs, holding others
accountable and moving forward
in a smart fashion. If you if
you wouldn't mind.
From the school perspective,
what is working? Is that what I
know now? It's how do we measure
it so that we can distill and
then apply what's working across
this immensely complex system in
California of close to a
thousand school districts and
more than 5000 schools, one of
the easiest way is by,
involvement from the kids. What
we see, in them progress in,
their well-being, their
attendance, the way they
interact with each other, what
type of social skills they're
developing. Because a lot of
that is not measured. When we
take the state test, all we're
measuring is how well they read
how well they write, and how
well they do in math. What the
you know, the school is holistic
education. It's a big piece of
big pie. And, there's lots of
pieces of that pie that that
need to be filled. And that's
one of them. So we're only
measuring, a very small portion
of what we could be measuring.
So my guess or recommendation
would be, what my goal is to
produce productive citizens,
global citizens of the world.
How do we measure that? I'm not
sure. I'm not a sociologist or
what, but I think we do need to
start measuring, how well the
students are doing in terms of
their development as human
beings. And as we know, as we've
talked about over and over again,
we're missing an opportunity
with a lot of these students, at
least from my perspective in the
elementary level, we've lost
literally generations of
potential talent, not just in
sports, but as we all heard,
that that translates into other
areas. So how we measure that,
I'm not sure. But I think that's
one thing that we need to start
measuring, like on state exams,
these these exams are very
limited. They really don't.
These kids that are coming up,
red or well below and all of
these standards are doing well
as human beings and, but there's
something in that they're doing
right, that makes them, whether
it's from the home or the family
or you have those teachers that
go the extra mile, or those
administrators that go the extra
mile to make sure that their
schools are run, holistically or
have comprehensive programs,
after the after school programs
as well. So I have to monitor
our after school program, to
make sure that it's being run
effectively, because sometimes
even those programs aren't
enough. Those programs aren't
run qualitatively. So I'm I'm
doing 2 or 3 different jobs at
once. So the after school
programs themselves need to be
monitored because those
programs, don't necessarily have
just like the teachers, the
training or the expertise,
that's another way we could
measure that, make sure that
those after school programs are
qualitatively run by competent
professionals, that they are
monitored because those those
programs are, again, a social
service for our students. And,
what I see sometimes on the yard
is some of the, some of the
coaches that are on their cell
phones, they're watching videos,
and the kids, here's a kickball
that. So, so if we can monitor
those a little bit more closely
because those systems in place
should in theory, work should be
helping our students, build
character, learn collaboration
skills because they're supposed
to be doing those activities
that the Playworks did earlier.
That's what the after school
programs are supposed to be
doing. They're supposed to be
doing those play work
activities, which we had at
Sixth Avenue when I was a
teacher way back when. And it
was incredible. But, funding got
cut and we had to choose between
a psychologist and a playworks
program. So we had to go with
the psychologist. So those are
things that I think could be
measured more monitored more
closely. That would help if we
made sure that those programs,
the after school programs in
particular, were run a little
bit more effectively and
qualitatively. I appreciate that.
And, Doctor Thompson, I know
this is something that you and
other researchers are looking
at. So yeah, so I think one
would be bringing back reporting
on state on student fitness
testing. It's mandated that
students take a fitness test.
But now we have no longer post
Covid. There's been no publicly
available data or the data is
not collected at the CDC level.
So being able to kind of have
our finger on the pulse of what
student cardiorespiratory
fitness looks like, what weight
weight status looks like, things
like that would be very valuable
to, I think having some sort of
mandated reporting around
whether or not you in elementary
schools, whether or not you have
a PE teacher and what a PE
schedule and what your recess
schedule are. I think that's
relatively simple. We know
people. There's misreporting and
self-report, but that's
something that parents can can
bring to their schools and help
them keep them accountable. And
then the last thing I'll mention
is that we have in California,
we have something called the
California Healthy Kids Survey
that has a main module that a
lot of students that a lot of
students across the state take.
We also have a physical activity
and nutrition model that was
taken by 12 schools last year.
12 schools elected to take it
because there's a cost
associated with it. So having
some sort of maybe not
necessarily testing, but some
sort of monitoring system around
that includes that includes
questions around physical
activity, mental health, socio
emotional health could be really
beneficial, for educators
themselves to kind of better
understand how their students
are doing. Thank you. And let me
say thank you to all of the
panelists, really grateful for
your generosity in time, but
also your insights today. Please
give them a big round of
applause, and if we could, we,
you know, as with every Senate
hearing, we'll take some time
for public comment. I think
there was there's a podium. We
can bring that up front. Any
members of the public who'd like
to comment? Please feel free,
we'd ask that you limit your
comments to approximately one
minute, but all of this will be
placed in the record and will be
of use for us moving forward. So
is there anybody here who would
like to comment publicly? Mr.
Really? Go ahead, Mr. Fisher. By
all means, please. I might be
even more generous with one
minute super quick. No because I
just turned 50, so I don't want
to forget, the one of one of the
sayings in coaching and in
sport, at the, at the school
level, whether it's grassroots,
high school, etc, is that you
can't out coach home. So no
matter how hard you're working
at school to coach your kids, a
certain way, you cannot out
coach what he or she is being
taught at home. So part of this
conversation can maybe include
are there some additional
resources that we can plan for
parents and families to also
play and move and learn? Are
there things on the weekends
where we can invite parents to
the school to move and play and
learn some of the healthy
information and play information
that they can take home, and
then reinforce what's happening
at school. That's it. Appreciate
that. I appreciate it wasn't
even a minute. So thank you. I
really do appreciate any other
members of the public would like
to comment, please. Thank you.
And yeah, I'm over 50 as well.
So, I do want to say thank you
for this opportunity to be able
to share about this as a
educator, as physical education,
one of the things mentioned was
having the proper and bringing
back the testing, which is so
important because and having it
to his point being explained and
expressed to our families and
how important that is, because
they're not connecting the dots
and not understanding how this
physical activity is working at
the home as well, and how it
works together. And for the
families as well. Educating them
on the importance of the example
of them being able to take
advantage and knowing what it is
for me as a parent, as a
guardian, as a caregiver,
providing that information for
my young one within the
community, within the school and
also, I wanted to add opening
the schools when they are not
being used is something that I
think is so important because it
brings community and our schools
together. So again, thank you
for this opportunity to be able
to share this. Can you say your
name and my name? Sure. Let
Hindi Newbill and I am a policy
educator for LAUSD. So yes,
thank you. And a former physical
education teacher. So yes, thank
you. Thank you. Any any other
members of the public. And I'd
ask as you start your name and
your affiliation. Thank you.
Hello everyone. My name is
Adriana Valenzuela. I oversee
health and physical education in
Los Angeles Unified School
District. I am a former PE
teacher and I have been
collaborating with all of our
teachers and administrators to
improve the state of physical
education, and particularly in
our district. And I just want to
focus on the physical education
piece, in particular to what the
state is doing to support
physical education, because I
see a disproportionate support
in regard to funding, there's a
lot of funding in regards to
arts, there's a lot of funding
for athletics. There's even more
funding for adaptive PE, which
is great, there is a lot of
emphasis on play. And after
school. But the physical
education teacher in
specifically at the early
grades, where it's even more
important to create movers out
of the little ones, it's not
necessarily supported, the, the
credentialing requirements for
an elementary teacher only
require one course, one course
in child development, which does
not give any elementary teacher
the skill to competently support
and promote these lifelong
skills that are important. And
because I want to make sure that
the credential teacher is given
the proper training and credit
because they need it, they have
this huge responsibility. As
you've seen, they have a huge
role in this. So I just want to
lobby for their support and for
the specific earmarking of
physical education. So that when
it does go to the local control
formula, it does make it to
where it's intended to go. Thank
you. Well put. Thank you. Next,
please. Hello. My name is
Matthew Bassett. I am a former
physical education teacher with
just over 22 years of service.
I'm currently working with the
districts and LA County at the
office of Education, helping
support their physical education
programs. I would like to
encourage you, as we talk about
some reform with the updating of
our standards and the framework
and also of the assessments that
have been given only in fitness,
that we want to expand upon it,
to reach out. There are some
amazing teachers around the
state doing amazing things.
There's an organization out
there that oversees us. They're
called the California
Association of Health, Physical
Education, Recreation and Dance.
Cabot is there to help us become
better teachers, and I would
love to see that you would
invite Capered as an
organization to have a seat at
the table to explain some of the
awesome things that are
happening in our state, the
people who are really invoking
positive change in the lives of
their students and creating a
positive learning environment,
and they would be the ones that
could help organize a team, a
committee, a group of
individuals that can help
change, help change our students
futures for the better. Thank
you. Thank you very much.
Anybody else? Yes please.
Welcome. Hi My name is Diana
madill. I'm also a boys and
girls club alumni and we have a
club, so I'll definitely invite
you for the alumni club, I
attended the boys and Girls
Clubs when I was young, and
that's where I first learned
about performance and dance. And
now I really just can't, you
know, stop moving my feet when I
hear a beat, so I'm grateful for
that. It was just a great
opportunity for me to learn that
dance was another avenue to
express my emotions, express my
feelings, and also learn how to
make friends in a new country, I
am so appreciative of each and
every one of you for hosting
this. I think we have been
screaming about this from a
rooftop, and it's really great
to finally hear that. There are
reports there, solutions that
are being talked about.
Additionally, I just want to
thank you for allowing us to
bring these programs to la USD
school students, we have a
clubhouse in the city of Carson,
and we are so proud to be able
to bring, you know, play to each
and every one of them in the
city of Carson, but I do want to
touch on some of the stuff that
was mentioned, specifically the
part of drop off where there is
drop off. So some of these
funding sources, like LP and
ACS, they don't reach our high
school students. And I'm not
saying to remove you know,
funding from this space to move
to the other, but I think we
need to find some creative
solutions to make sure that
there is equity, when we brought
some of our students to
Sacramento, visited with,
Senator Cuevas and, and
Bradford, they learned that they
were not getting the same
funding that their peers were.
And our students were upset,
rightfully so. And so we're
using also this as an avenue to
educate them on advocacy and how
they can support each other in
their community. And the last
thing I'll share is about
partnerships that are very, very
critical. We have to come up
with some partnership solutions
between cities, between
foundations, between nonprofits
and our government. Elected
officials to make sure that
we're catching all of the
students that are falling
through the cracks, and boys and
girls Clubs is more than happy
to jump on and support with
that. Thank you. Thank you,
thank you very much. Any other
members of the public would like
to comment? Okay. Seeing none to
my colleagues, any any brief
words to close, I just want to
say thank you so much for the
organizers of today's events and
all of the presenters just
learned an incredible amount. I
think a whole 360 view of this
issue, looking forward to more
partnership, looking forward to
getting a soccer field up in the
Baldwin Hills. Kenneth Hahn Park
area. We're working together
with Renato on that and allies,
but you know what I'm taking
away from this, and you gave
great takeaways, Renata. But
this is about our future and how
healthy we will be, how
disciplined we will be, what
kind of relationships we can
build as a community, as
California. So I think this is
so much of a priority. And
you've shined a light on it
today in a way that helps us
understand why this issue needs
to be prioritized. And I want to
just say, thank you so much for
everyone who participated. Thank
you. And I and I just, I just
what my colleague said and just
say thank you. And, and I think
today has stressed the
importance of movement
regardless of whether it's
through sports, through dance,
through just walking and
exercising and what it does to
our overall well-being and how
it helps us develop and the
interaction that is required
there. So I just want to say
thank you. I would just only add
that I didn't hear anything
about golf. And as a, as a
golfer, really, I started a
junior golf program and I would
love to see a lot more young
folks involved in that, too,
because it's a lot of exercise.
A lot of people don't think that
as a sport, but it is very
strenuous as Mr. Zamora will
tell you, Mr. Fisher has learned
since his NBA days. So I just
want to add that that we have
started a junior golf program
and want to encourage young
folks to experience that as
well. So thank you. I thank you.
And so let me, for my part, as
the chair of the committee,
thank you so much to all of the
panelists, and as my colleagues,
this is an important
conversation. And there is a
reflex in legislative circles to
minimize or often even dismiss
the importance of play, of
physical education as we deal
with all of the other pressing
issues that confront California.
But as you've heard from our
panelists and other witnesses
today, you know, play is so
important as a foundation for
personal development, for
healthy growth and as Senator
and I were discussing during the
break, you know, quite often we
get caught up at the legislative
level in, you know, kind of the
intricacies of things, you know,
and all these acronyms you've
heard today. Lcap Lcff, Elab,
CDE, the supplemental Assist,
you know, and you can lose sight
of what is actually important.
And what's important is play to
give students over the course of
a day, over the course of a year,
opportunities for the kinds of
outlets and development that
otherwise not only won't be had,
but that are so complementary to
everything else that we're
trying to do in education. And
as Renata mentioned, it's
crucial. And as I would add, it
is urgent. And one thing that we
can't do as a legislature is
develop more five year plans,
because every five year plan
excludes five years of kids who
need the attention and the
resources urgently. So with
that, I am really grateful we
will take that with us. I fully
intend to do some legislation
next year that is squarely aimed
at solving some of these
problems. I thank everyone here
for your participation. I want
to thank Derek Fisher, who
stayed way longer than I
expected, a five time NBA
champion, and be careful, sir,
we may we may invite you back up
to Sacramento to be a witness,
as we do some legislation. But
to Renata and to Fernando at LA
for to everybody who helped to
Cordell Hampton, on my staff.
Thank you, and I look forward to
continuing this conversation
with all of you. And thank you
to my colleagues as well. And
with that, this hearing of the
education committee is adjourned.